[Música]
oi meu nome é júlia tenho 11 anos e hoje
vou falar sobre os grupos interativos
vocês saibam que o grupo interativo é
como o próprio nome diz é uma atividade
interativa onde trocamos nossas idéias e
aprendemos juntos como muitas vezes que
houve algo de um colega que eu não tinha
pensado antes e isso é bem interessante
é o grupo interativo é formado por um
agrupamento dos alunos com o que fazemos
atividades de revisão com a ajuda da
professora e de voluntários
nesses grupos têm a presença de pessoas
voluntárias que é um pai ou uma monitora
da escola
os voluntários ajudam os alunos a se
concentrarem este estimulam as
interações e cada um tem um jeito
diferente de conduzir o grupo é como se
a professora se dividir se em várias
estivesse presente em todos os grupos e
eles dão apoio às nossas necessidades
ao todo fazemos cinco atividades que são
de língua portuguesa e matemática
temos 15 minutos para fazer cada uma
delas são grupos de seis ou sete alunos
cada grupo realiza uma atividade
diferente é feito um rodízio de forma
que todos os voluntários passem por
todos os grupos e todos fazem todas as
lições ao final de uma hora e meia todos
terão realizado com sucesso as cinco
atividades professor organiza explica e
orienta pessoa voluntária ela acompanha
o desenvolvimento dos grupos interativos
de fora mas se necessário nos ajuda
sabe por que eu gosto do grupo
interativo porque eu gosto de ajudar em
de ensinar e de saber o que o colega
pensa e da ajuda dos voluntários
com isso eu
descobri que os grupos interativos
reforçam e aceleram a prender o aprender
é compartilhado por todos e todos são
responsáveis pela aprendizagem como
quando um colega não consegue fazer sua
actividade nos dedicamos a ajudá lo e
assim aprendemos a ser solidários
eu aprendo conversando e com ajuda todos
conseguem resolver com sucesso as
atividades propostas
obrigado
[Aplausos]